so I'll just give my introduction once
more here for folks who have just joined
right now uh sorry to bug your flow
folks who are introducing so I'm Russia
I'm your host and I'm from joining from
Bangalore India uh we would love to know
where are you joining from here on chat
so yeah feel free to tell us where
you're joining from a chat or if you
have anything to add uh yeah awesome
start in few minutes
thank you
[Music]
also I can see introductions are still
coming in so folks to have just joined
in right now just to let you know
starting in just few minutes and today
we are going to talk about IIT kanpur's
professional certificate program in AIML
and this is a career master class so if
you're wondering how to achieve Mastery
in AIML this is the right place to be
and also just to let you know that if
you have a question related to AIML uh
or particularly towards this program IIT
conference program you what you can do
is you can put down your queries in the
Q a box uh good thing is we have already
started getting questions in the Q a box
uh for folks that have joined in early
so that's great that doesn't happen
usually so that's great we have gotten
really good interactive audience here
we're getting a lot of introductions on
chat I can see folks have joined from
Tamil Nadu chaitanya has joined from
Andhra Pradesh just to let you know that
I am joining from uh Bangalore India
and would love to know where you're
joining from
we'll just start in a few minutes
awesome uh so yeah
okay we have folks joining from Kenya
iOS Colorado as well that's great
I can see somebody from West Bengal hey
hi I can see Vijay from Mumbai
I can see someone I joined from haridwar
awesome we have we are getting folks
from different different parts of the
world as well that's that's great
okay I can see Sharon joining from us
but is from Pune
us
awesome awesome folks we're just
starting in few minutes
keep the introductions coming in it's
always a good place to network you know
in these Live Events I'll tell you
I mean I can see folks from Argentina
Pakistan as well awesome awesome welcome
folks uh we'll be starting the session
in few minutes
joining us now
I'm joining from Hyderabad Russia
well uh awesome we have gotten you a lot
of folks from Hyderabad here as well on
chat yeah I see that yes just now I can
see ikra has joined from Hyderabad hi I
can see Ronald from Delhi I think we can
start I think folks are still joining in
but I think we can start with few ground
rules and introduction uh before we
start the session uh so uh before we go
ahead so uh today's career master class
is about how you can achieve Mastery in
AIML uh through this IIT campus Cutting
Edge course uh so let's start with few
ground rules so uh all you need to do is
you need to put down your questions in
the Q a box in case you have any queries
if you're putting those questions in the
chat box I am so sorry we might miss it
because we get a lot of messages
messages on chat you can see that right
now the introductions are still coming
in uh so keep that up and uh the session
will be recorded so you can expect a
follow-up mail with recording link and
also bonus offer and uh to basically
request to prefer attendance because
you'll be getting a certificate for this
webinar as well so you can provide your
name in the post webinar survey that is
a really good tip you know so I'm just
passing it on to you
and let's start with getting to know you
uh better so before we start we would
love to know like how many years of
experience do you have
so you can see a very quick poll on your
screen and uh there are four easy
options if you're currently studying you
can select that option if you have zero
to three years of experiencing and
selling the second one if you have three
to five years of experience you can say
like the third one if you have more than
five years of experience you can select
the fourth one so I can see the pores
moving in we have gotten a very
interactive and active audience here in
terms of post participation my mistake
so we're just getting to know you better
so we can help you out better so how
much experience do you have it's an easy
question quick before you can see on
your screen uh so you can see the first
one if you're currently studying you can
see the second one you have zero to
three years of experience if you have a
immediate level of experience of three
to five years you can sell like the
third one if you have more than five
years of experience you can select the
fourth one
I can see most of the folks have voted
uh only a few other folks who have not
voted I would suggest I'll be giving 10
seconds more uh you can go ahead and
vote for an answer answer suitable to
your experience
awesome I can see the polls moving still
so we'll give it 10 seconds more for
other folks who are left to vote in
also uh while you are actually voting uh
in the poll just to let you know I'm
pretty sure you have a lot of questions
so what you can do is you can put down
your questions the Q a box surprisingly
we already have gotten a few questions
in the Q a box before starting the
session so that's really great that's an
advantage you know you're putting down
your questions right there uh and I'm
pretty sure you will have more questions
during the session
yeah if you are putting that over
that I might miss it so I'm really sorry
for that so yeah okay I'll be closing
the poll in five seconds few of the
folks who have not voted uh so five four
three two one so I've been in the poll
now thank you so much for voting
so let me share the results so if you
can see that we have gotten almost half
of the folks who are currently studied
another half of the folks who have more
than five years of experience that's
great and uh I can see a few folks who
have zero to three years of experience
and few other folks who have three to
five years of experience so thank you so
much for sharing your experience so we
can help you better moving on uh we'll
be talking about the agenda of the
session so obviously we'll be getting to
know more about you so we can understand
how to help you out better and
understand make you understand this
career path towards Ai and machine
learning and we will be also talking
about what this program exactly offers
and how this program will get you job
ready and we'll be taking you through
the enrollment steps and there will be a
special session for the Q a part as well
so I'll make sure that we take few
questions during the webinar uh but
towards the end of the session we'll
make sure that we actually take all the
questions related to AML you know uh for
that particular session so yeah please
have some patience and uh please go and
put down your questions in the Q in a
box I can see them coming while I'm
speaking so that's great I can see an
attentive audience here so yeah
uh also we have our speaker here with us
today
uh will be taking us through the PCP
program in AIML uh with IIT kanpur uh
would you like to give us your
introduction
sure thanks Russia uh hello everyone
delighted to be here with all of you
today uh just to give you a quick
introduction I pulled an MBA degree and
then I had the privilege of accumulating
over 16 years of invaluable corporate
experience uh my journey in the
corporate world has been defined by my
passion for analytics and statistical
concept which has driven me to excel in
the field of training delivery and
analytics product development over the
years I have had the incredible
opportunity to work with some remarkable
organizations and individuals and
privilege of training corporate
organizations in data science artificial
intelligence and machine learning
accumulating over 4500 hours of training
experience and it's been a deeply
rewarding experience to empower
professionals with the Knowledge and
Skills to harness the power of these
transformative Technologies
and in addition to my training and there
was uh I also uh
um I have also co-founded a trainee
sorry a company called intellitica uh
where we specialize in crafting data
driven solution uh our mission is to
leverage incredible potential of data to
solve real world problem and drive
Innovations so that's what I have been
doing and in terms of
uh corporate training that I have I'm
doing with simple learn I have more than
150 clients but I have delivered
training programs and I'm also dealing
there
dealing with their uh Celtic and Purdue
program so this is just in a nutshell
what I have been doing awesome thank you
for the great introduction uh and uh so
this program is powered by simply learn
and we are very proud to call us world's
number one online bootcamp and we are
also very proud that we have trained
five million plus Professionals in over
150 plus countries and we have been in
this digital space for almost 13 years
and we are very proud that we are
transforming lives by empowering people
by digital skills so welcome again uh
for folks who have just joined right now
so we're starting with about careers in
Ai and machine learnings I can see
questions coming in about career or in
the Q a box so uh before we start
how does this AIML course align with
ai's job growth and creation given the
statistics which are shown here
um actually if you look at it uh it says
here that uh Forbes is
is claiming that the annual growth rate
would be
37.3 percent from 2023 to 2030 which is
actually humongous if you compare with
any other industry at the moment Ai and
machine learning is growing with leaps
and bound and uh the understanding that
you have to have from this is that it's
not something which you need to be
worried about it's actually going to
extend your capabilities that's what the
whole idea is so AI machine learning
will go hand in hand with us with with
human and we will be solving some more
complex problems in in future with uh
with lesser amount of time that's what
the whole idea is and and and this
growth which is which we are talking
about here which always it will also uh
give you a lot of opportunity not only
in terms of creating a lot of employment
but also in terms of creating a lot of
lot of companies a lot of startups which
will be working in this particular
domain solving new problems and all so
this is what we will be doing
awesome uh also let's talk about what
are the career paths you know that you
can
you can ask skills elaborate
lab range of career options that
individuals can pursue within this
Dynamic field of AIA
[Music]
sure so as you see on the screen we have
different uh options when it comes to
your your career in Ai and ML and and
sometimes it gets confusing also so I'll
give you a little understanding that
what all these these career paths are
like we start with the machine learning
engineer so
so the the role would be uh we will be
machine learning Engineers focus on
designing implementing and maintaining
machine Learning System and they work on
developing algorithms training models
deploying them into production
environments uh skills if you talk about
for machine learning Engineers uh uh
Proficiency in programming languages
like python knowledge of machine
learning libraries like tensorflow Pi
touch are very critic by touch are very
critical when you talk about data
Engineers they are responsible for
building and maintaining the data
infrastructure of an organization the
design and manage databases data
pipelines and ETL which will be which
will be kind of foundation for machine
learning project or data science project
that we talk about skills would be uh
mainly revolved around SQL no SQL data
warehousing data integration tools that
that we talk about
uh AI architect when you talk about they
are responsible for Designing the
overall AI strategy and architecture of
an organization they make high level
decision regarding which Ai and machine
learning Technologies to implement to
achieve specific business goals and
skills over here would be a deep
expertise in Ai and machine learning
with a with a very good understanding of
business requirement that's what is very
essential for AI architect
and when you talk about AI developers
they focus on creating applications and
software that incorporate Ai and machine
learning capabilities they work on
coding testing deploying AI algorithms
in real world applications and
Proficiency in programming language
machine learning libraries and AI
framework will be very crucial then you
have data scientists data scientists
extracts
they extract valuable insights from the
data so they apply statistical analysis
and machine learning techniques to solve
complex problems and generate actionable
recommendations from the for decision
making and here also you need to have
strong background a strong understanding
of programming platforms data analysis
machine learning data visualization
libraries and when I'm explaining you
these these these roles you will see
that there are certain overlap in one
from one role to another which happens
and depending on the organizations they
might have some of the role uh design
which will have which will have
responsibility mixed up which happens
but this is on a broad level what each
one of them they mean
awesome thank you so much for taking us
to the career paths uh also we have we
will be talking about what are the
up-to-date skills uh to be an aim
practitioner uh how does this course
ensure Learners are equipped with the
latest AI email skills needed in
practice
but how it goes is basically if you are
thinking to start build your career in
this particular field you need to start
with the foundational skills and that's
where statistics and maths come into the
picture which is pretty important and I
see sometimes that people try to skip
this particular part and directly jump
to the machine learning algorithm and
then then get into trouble later on so I
would strongly recommend start with the
foundational skills which is into
statistics and maths which is very
essential python it's libraries that is
the tool right now for machine learning
and AI so start with that then as you
move along you will you will need to
learn about different learning
algorithms which is your supervised run
supervised learning reinforcement
learning within that framework you'll
have Ensemble learning or you talk about
recommendation system these are the
learning methods that you have to learn
and then eventually you have to move to
the advanced part of the machine
learning that's where the Deep learning
and the latest advancement in the in the
Deep learning would come into the
picture so you will be working with
neural networks we'll be talking about
uh working with the images working with
the speech and then generating AI which
is the top of the Town these days
everyone is talking about generative Ai
and and how chat GPT has actually
changed the entire way of functioning of
anyone who is into this particular
domain so so this is how uh you should
go about learning the skills start with
the foundational skills then machine
learning and then Advanced machine
learning that we'll talk about
awesome uh I just wanted to ask the
question that there's always my right
where you get
distortions here right
that's there but uh whether whether you
go for a machine learning engineer uh
career path or you go for uh on the data
scientist path it doesn't matter you
have to have foundational skills which
is basically starts with a very basic
statistics and that is very essential
because until unless you do not
understand what data is or what type of
data is you will not be able to
understand what kind of machine learning
algorithm I can apply so it is as simple
as that so you cannot jump the gun over
here you need to start with the
statistics and take this particular path
which has been shown on your screen this
is pretty much nicely curated over here
you start with the basics move towards
machine learning algorithm and
eventually go to the advanced topic of
machine learning
well thank you so much for answering
that
uh so you have basically talked about
the skills you've talked about the
career path uh and I know that you're
here because you actually are interested
in the eiml program by it Carnival so
what exactly is stopping you from taking
this AI annual certification uh if you
can see a quick poll on the screen here
this is a multiple choice question you
can select multiple options uh this is
to understand what exactly is the
problem we are facing so we can help you
out better uh with those answers uh so
following the webinar so I can see our
folks have started voting already uh for
the basically what's stopping them from
taking the AIML certification so I'll
just uh tell the first option the uh
basically the first one is I can't find
a fully comprehensive curriculum uh
second one is I wouldn't get the
practical exposure I need to become an
LED I am an expert I find it difficult
to learn from pre-recorded videos as the
third one and the fourth one is my work
schedule won't allow me enough time for
learning so let's see what is your
biggest concern so tell us what exactly
is your biggest concern uh basically
which is stopping you from taking the
aims certification
so you can see a quick pull on screen uh
we have gotten a very active audience
here so most of the folks have already
won
so sorry uh so yeah I can see the polls
are still moving so I'll be closing the
poll in 10 seconds so few of the folks
who have not voted please go and vote uh
this is just to know that what exactly
is the biggest concern you have related
to picking the eiml certification so we
can help you out better
and folks who have already finished the
poll uh I can see ronak you have put
down a question on the chat please put
it on in the Q a section because we get
a lot of messages in the chat uh that
will be really helpful you know when we
take the Q a questions I'll make sure
that a question get answers and for
others as well so while we do that uh so
I'll be closing the poll in five seconds
I can see most of the folks have already
voted so awesome
so I'll be closing the poll in five
seconds so five
four three two one so let me just end
the poll and share the results
so as we can see uh the biggest concern
here is uh they can't find a fully
comprehensive curriculum and another
biggest concern is my work schedule
won't allow me enough time for learning
and a few of them have said that I
wouldn't get the Practical exposure I
need to become a email expert and uh a
few of them have said that I find it
difficult to learn from 3D content
videos so uh let's talk about the IIT
campus course uh and take you through
more in-depth detail about the course
so the IIT campus or professional
certificate course in EI machine
learning uh offers your comprehensive
and Industry aligned learning path uh
you get to work on integrated Hands-On
labs and projects for practical
experience and you get access to online
virtual classrooms with live peer and
instructor interaction and we make sure
that it is flexible to fit your schedule
for folks who have chosen the option
that they don't find enough time to
basically complete the course that is
what is stopping them and the program
duration for this one is 11 months and
you can just complete it by giving 10 to
15 hours per week uh and this program
for IIT kanpur is an industry learning
path amitendra can you tell us what
happens in the live learning class like
does it only have a live lecture or does
it offer more than that actually the the
whole program is centered about giving
you understanding how a concept works
and then how do you implement on a
real-time problem so the idea is this
that uh we take up a particular concept
or we explain you how does it work in
the live session and the instructor
would be there we'll be explaining these
Concepts they will be giving you what
the intuition behind the concept how the
how does the math work and then what
kind of problem we can solve with that
and eventually uh we take up a case
study and while solving the case study
we explain you how it's getting
implemented it's entirely Hands-On
program where you get to learn the
concept and and parallelly you will be
able to implement on a given problem so
not only you understand the concept you
will know in real life that where you
need to implement it and that's what is
pretty important as well
awesome and uh do you think like uh with
lemon 11 months of duration and with
only just 10 to 15 hours per week uh
like someone can become an a ml expert
with this IIT conference course
I would say it's a good start in a sense
that it's called comprehensive program
which talks about different concepts
which are dealt in Ai and machine
learning it depends on the individuals
also how Keen they are in terms of
learning although we talk about 10 to 15
hours of every week that way you can
cover uh all the topics which is
generally used in this particular domain
and with a little more practice means
I'm not saying that you you take a lot
of time but with practice you'll become
expert at these these Concepts so 11
months when when we talk about it's a
quite a good amount of time and uh it's
a it's a quite comprehensive program
which is getting covered in 11 months
actually
well that's great uh let's move on uh
basically what exactly you get in this
program as well so you get a program
completion certificate from E and ICD
Academy IIT kanpur uh also you get
exposure to latest trends like
generative AI prompt engineering LGBT
and more and you get to work on hands
and products in integrated Labs
including a Capstone project which we'll
be talking about more and uh you will be
also getting access to master classes uh
which are delivered by distinguished IAT
kanpa faculty so that's a really good
advantage to have and also moving on to
the IIT kanpur Advantage uh so I think
we all know about IIT in general but IIT
kanpur was established in 1959 and uh an
interesting fact about it that uh it
basically was responsible for launching
uh the space shuttle aryamata uh you
know moving uh back you know uh there
and IIT also is home to National
blockchain project and internal
disability Center for cyber security and
cyber defense of critical infrastructure
uh and also obviously having a IIT can't
put on your CD is a prestigious
accomplishment so uh what do you think
like what exactly is the IAT company
Advantage uh you know you have six
students taking it up that is a good
brand to have it on your CV first of all
because there's this ages and nobody can
question the the authority of IIT car
any of the iits for that matter and uh
having said that you have mentioned it
is uh Center for cyber security and
cyber defense of critical infrastructure
National blockchain project so that that
speaks itself that that uh how uh
renowned this particular Institute is
awesome uh thank you so much and uh
we'll be talking about the eligibility
and pay request sites uh so you need to
have a prior knowledge or experience in
programming in mathematics and you need
to have a bachelor degree with an
average of 50 of higher marks uh having
a two plus year of formal work
experience is preferred uh amiting like
having a prior knowledge or experience
in programming and Mathematics does that
act as a plus uh while you're digging up
this course yes that would be uh acting
as a plus point because you will have
understanding of those Concepts which
are getting dealt in beforehand so you
will be able to catch up with the with
the sessions very fast and uh some some
prior knowledge is always helpful in in
these programs
awesome
uh we'll be talking about how this
program basically prepares you uh so
we'll be talking about how this program
builds your cyber security skills step
by steps and get you already uh can you
take us
uh through how this program builds your
cyber security skill step by step so
basically uh it starts with the
mathematic and statistical essential and
if you recall I was talking about when
you want to make your career in this
particular field you have to have a good
understanding of some of the statistical
Concepts along with that some
mathematics as well because most of the
machine learning algorithms are
basically optimization algorithms with
lot of computation which happens so if
you have good understanding of
mathematics you will have deeper
understanding of those algorithm and
eventually you'll be able to fine tune
in a better manner so that's where this
particular section comes where we talk
about mathematics and statistics
essential for machine learning and
machine learning related field and it
also covers your programming Refreshers
it talks about basics of programming so
that you will be ready for for the for
the for the next section which is
applied data science with python which
talks about Concepts which are very
essential for for uh data pre-processing
that we talk about or before machine
learning what you are doing with the
data think that way so it talks about
Concepts like data wrangling or
exploratory data analysis it meant it
covers your
data acquisition functionalities or
probably how to clean the data how to do
feature engineering so basically
whatever work goes at the data preparing
stage all that will be covered in
applied data data science with python
now here we talked about Concepts that
is important from uh feature extraction
or feature engineering perspective and
then we also help you to apply those
Concepts on the given data that's how it
goes so that is that is your applied
data sense but python then you have a
machine learning program that's where we
talk about different machine learning
algorithms it will cover your supervised
learning and unsupervised learning
within supervised learning framework you
will be taught different regression
algorithm different classification
algorithm your Ensemble learning how do
you build these models how do you
evaluate them how do you how do you fine
tune them so all that will be taught to
you and all this will be dealt as I
mentioned earlier also you'll be taught
a taught a particular concept and then
you will be implementing on the data in
the classroom itself with the with the
help of the instructor
and after machine learning is done then
you will move to deep learning and deep
learning with Krause and tensorflow
which focuses upon the neural networks
how do you build neural networks
different kind of neural networks we
talked about convolutional neural
network character neural networks or it
could be Auto encoder so all those
networks how do you build what kind of
problem you are solving what libraries
are required which is basically this is
focusing on Keras and tensorflow and
then again how do you implement on a
given problem so that's what will be
Delta over there then you have
Essentials of generative AI prompt
engineering and chart GPT now generative
AI has become very critical these days
you must be listening to all the
advancement which is happening in this
particular field so starting from Gans
and then variational Auto encoders and
all to your chart GPT or it could be
other virtual assistant that we have
been talking about or LMS that we have
been using so that will be delt over are
there so it will talk about prompt
engineering how do you do the prompting
actually and how to mix make how to how
to create some some smart prompts
actually so that's what we'll be dealing
with
and then eventually you'll have a
Capstone so now this Capstone project is
designed to test your understanding of
all these sections that you have covered
so it will have a very comprehensive
case study I'll say a comprehensive
project which will have different
sections covering different parts that
you have covered in the entire program
and this gives you a lot of
understanding that how a particular
project gets handled in a real-time
scenario and uh and also it gives you a
lot of confidence once you solve it so
that's why the Capstone project is now
in addition to that you also have
electives so you can choose
reinforcement learning as an elective or
or a couple of them it's not that only
one you can select so you have
reinforcement learning which talks about
how you learn by trial and error method
you have advanced deep learning and
computer vision focus is solely upon
your image processing and and talks
about object detection and all you have
natural language processing and speech
recognition and also
academic and Industry master classes
which would be dealt by industry
professionals and and and and
lectures coming from your from from IIT
kanpur so that's your master class this
is how the entire program is
wow thank you so much for taking us
through the steps uh so the electives uh
they are actually optional uh but it
does come from uh as a part of the
program so we do not charge anything
extra for it but it is up to you if you
want to take it up that's more than
great so yeah
so now moving on uh the about the tools
the libraries or the platforms and I'm
pretty sure all the tools here which
we're seeing here like the python chart
GPT uh kubernetes I'm pretty sure there
are many more uh tools platforms and
libraries you know which this program
covers amitendra can you take us through
these uh in-demand tools and like
religious and platforms maybe give give
the audience an idea exactly uh what
they will be learning uh in this program
sure so basically when you talk about
the entire machine learning life cycle
starting from your problem statement and
eventually when you're deploying it so
you go through different uh stages and
and every stage has a different kind of
Challenge and different kind of
requirements so right from data
acquisition to data pre-processing data
preparation model building you will be
dealing with different kinds of
libraries which are suitable for that
particular task and that way you'll be
learning a lot many libraries not only
which are mentioned over here so it
talks about say NLT knltk is for natural
language toolkit so if you are working
with the text Data you come across this
particular Library similarly Keras
tensorflow is a live this this is a
framework developed for deep networks
deep neural networks that we talked
about deep learning so so those are the
libraries similarly matplotlib I can use
for data visualization chart GPT I think
now now you guys understand where we are
using chat GPT sqln is a machine
learning library equivalent needs our
flask we use for machine learning
deployment open AI gym is for for your
reinforcement learning so that these are
some of the libraries which are
mentioned over here but in addition to
these you'll be learning few more but
this is what we are covering over here
awesome I think those are pretty
interesting tools and liabilities and
now talking about about projects I
I just before uh I just have a question
from the crowd that how does uh working
on these projects the three-year
business amplifications uh gets you the
real uh World experience you know and
gets your job ready
and basically how it goes is uh once you
start solving from problem uh and that
also from different domains like the
couple of that you have mentioned is
retail coming from production or bfsi so
once you start solving the problems and
these are some real-time problem it's
not that it's made up so these are the
real-time problems so once you start
solving then you get the entire
understanding that how it works in the
real-time scenario what are the steps I
have to take one of the problem that
people face is that that once they get
into a real-time real real world problem
they don't know where to start and once
you have solved all these these these
projects these case studies you'll have
a very good understanding that what are
the steps you have to take how to take
it forward and how to finish it off so
so that that gives you a lot of idea
that that uh how you're gonna take up a
problem statement break it down into
small component and then build your
machine learning model and deploy it
also it gives you idea like all these
projects gives you an understanding that
what kind of different problems people
are solving in different domains
different vertical so that also is
pretty important so these These are the
benefits you will derive from here gives
you a lot of confidence once you have
solved all these projects and cases
which are mentioned in this on your
screen wow that's uh that's pretty
helpful actually for folks who are just
starting off in AML as a career option
right uh also uh we have talked about
the Capstone project and the hive of
caption project so maybe I would love to
know that how does having a Capstone
project on your CV boost your basically
job applications so when you're actually
trying to you know get out there get job
ready post just completing the
certificate as well
now basically what happens generally if
you talk about an interview when you
mention any caps shown uh the questions
will be asked like first of all it shows
that you have solved some some some
comprehensive uh project it gives you
that idea and because you have solved it
on your own you'll be able to you will
be able to explain how a machine
learning project life cycle work and
which is very essential when you are
actually applying for a particular job
and they want to understand if you have
the thorough
tomorrow understanding of these Concepts
or not so basically what happens is once
you have this mentioned on your CV you
can easily explain what you have done
because you have solved it entirely and
and and with that perspective you will
be able to explain that what are the
steps you have taken what kind of
challenges you have faced how did you
sort out those challenges what kind of
additional steps you could have taken to
make it make it even better that those
kind of ideas you can give so the having
a Capstone on your CV gives this
understanding to the to the to the
organizations that you have worked on a
real life problem you understand how it
works out in in in reality you also
understand that how to utilize different
libraries different framework to solve a
particular problems that's how it will
be helpful
oh oh that's that's really good uh I can
see the potential of having a capsule
project you know in your resume oppose
the certification as well uh that's
great uh now uh we have a simple learn
Community also that supports you uh so
the Learners will be getting access to
instructors program manager cohort
manager uh learning teams and peers and
also getting access to curriculum and
resources so there's a community which
actually supports you and you can go and
raise your questions there you know
whatever you have during your uh
certification process uh the LMS
learning environment is something our
material will be taking us through
giving you a live experience of exactly
what happens when you take up the course
uh but in this learning environment we
will be talking about how you can manage
your curriculum amitan will be
showcasing the full learning path uh how
you are can access the live virtual
classroom and where are the labs and
projects you can perform them out as
well uh the testing assessments the
caption project which we already talked
about and also for unlocking your
certificate basically once you are done
with your program uh the progress
tracking screen will also be there and
also there'll be support tools which
will be available 24 7 for you as well
from secreting can you take us through
the learning environment
sure
just give me a sec
okay so once you uh enroll for a program
you will be given access to the LMS and
once you log into your LMS depending on
the program that you have chosen uh the
course will be listed and I'm just
giving you one of the uh program that I
have access for so here once you once
you log into your LMS the the program
will be mentioned over there you click
on that particular program like apply
data science with python is one of the
section that I have explained to you
when I was talking about different
different sections that we covered in
this
program over here so once you go over
there uh you will get this self-learning
videos over there so you have the
self-learning videos which is just kind
of a hell uh uh pre-recorded video just
to help you to get started with these
Concepts it doesn't mean that you have
to watch this and learn from it this is
just for your for your help purpose
nothing else so you get the
self-learning video then you also get
options
so here's when I go to the learning
track here I was talking about
self-learning videos so you get this
self learning you get the live classes
option you get the assessment over here
so everything is a single place so
so see here once I go to the self
learning module this is just for your
help purpose
it lists down all the sections which are
there in the self learning here this
side
so you have like course introduction
then you have introduction to data
science essential Python Programming
numpy and all then you have option for
live classes over here you can click on
that and
whatever classes are scheduled for you
will appear over here you will have the
joining link there itself and you can
join the classes from here
also after the classes are over which is
in structural LED it's not a
pre-recorded video that you are watching
Once the classes are over you will have
your recording of the class available
here itself so in case if you want to go
back to the concept that has been dealt
and you want to just watch it again and
make some notes you can do that so that
learning those videos will be over here
then you have a assessment tab over here
if you see so assessment tab basically
will will talk about the project that
you are supposed to finish in this
particular section this is not a
Capstone this is a project which is part
of your applied data science with python
here
okay so you have two projects one of
them you have to solve and you have to
you have to submit and when you go to
any of these projects it gives you the
entire description what's the problem
statement list on all the
questions gives you a word file which
will have all the questions everything
you will have the data here itself
and then you are supposed to solve and
submit
so that's your assessment now while
learning these Concepts when the
instructor is teaching you they might be
using some presentation some data set
and some notebooks as well so all that
reference material is available here
itself you don't have to go somewhere
else just download these ebooks which is
which are the presentations used in the
classroom your code file will be over
here and then data set which is getting
used in the code file
are over here which will be utilized in
the classroom so you don't have to go to
any other place download everything from
here and keep it handy whenever you are
going for a live class
then you also have a certificate section
once you finish this particular
assessment you will your certified will
get unlocked then when you want to work
on a data set or when you want to work
while learning from the instructor you
can go to the practice lab and you can
launch the lab and you can start working
on the problems
inside the lab here you don't have to
actually install anything on your system
it's a it's a pre-loaded lab which has
everything in it like all the libraries
that you need and all you need to do you
need to Simply log in launch and start
working on it
so the lab appears like this and this is
just to give you a little perspective
that one of the session which I am
I I'm taking at the moment just to give
a little perspective so this is how it
comes I'm talking about say data
wrangling just a second guys
okay sorry for that okay so here I was
talking about if I'm if I'm teaching
data wrangling in my classroom so this
is how it will go I'll talk about
different concepts and while
while talking about those Concepts I'll
ask you that okay let's do one thing
let's import the data and let's work on
the data and and then we'll go one by
one each of these Concepts implementing
on the data and then that and then
eventually
will give you some some exercises to
work upon and that's how it goes so you
so you learn everything in the lab
notebooks are shared in that one in
advance so you don't have to actually
you don't have to actually go different
places for downloading the data or the
notebook so this is how typically a
session goes where we talk about
different concepts and we Implement in
the data then in the lab you also have
uh options for taking notes if you want
to write it down something you can take
notes here you have a Community Support
over here in case uh you want to you you
you got stuck at some place and you need
help you can you can log into the
community link and you can put up your
question and our set of trainers are
available 24x7 and we answer those
queries which one is put up put in the
community then you have a help button
also over here in case if something is
creating a problem for you some issue is
happening you can raise a ticket it will
be sorted out in no time
so that's how your LMS function this is
basically quite comprehensive in a sense
that you get everything at one place you
don't have to roam around here and there
to First accumulate all the material and
then start learning everything is
already curated for you all you need to
do is you need a system which can which
is which has a browser just log in and
start working so that's what the LMS is
all about
awesome thank you so much for taking us
through the LMS uh folks uh I'm pretty
sure you might have uh questions about
the LMS environment or about the IIT
canvas course we're getting a lot of
questions we'll be taking those in some
time uh meanwhile just let me share my
screen back
uh
I hope my screen is
um so uh thank you uh so we have uh
global leaders as program director uh
Professor Army as well uh who works in
the department of computer science and
engineering and all in from ID kanpur uh
we uh basically these global leaders
make sure that simply learn is
delivering as per the standards to IIT
kanpur uh about this program uh we'll be
talking about the learner outcomes I can
see folks uh have asked about the
learner outcomes on the chat uh so uh
interesting thing is the previous
classes have consistent of Learners from
world-class organizations and iOS
Industries uh uh basically Learners join
from IIT consultancy and other bfsis and
other Industries and the hiring
companies uh we have is Amazon cognizant
Infosys star charge impact Delight City
Wells Fargo ey and many more
so uh just want to know like are you
interested in enrolling in this program
by IIT kanpur for AIA and
so you can see a quick poll on your
screen all you need to do is Select an
option uh so yes or no more so uh are
you interested in enrolling in this
program uh of IIT kanpur's artificial
intelligence and machine learning
so you can see a quick poll on the
screen
I must say the audience is pretty
responsive here so you've gotten a great
audience here great set of Learners here
who are curious about EI ml I can see
from the questions we have gotten in the
Q a box which I am excited to take up
those questions you know as soon as
possible we are done with this phone
so yeah
so uh would you like to enroll in this
program uh so you can see a quick
polling screen uh the program IET campus
professional certificate program in
artificial intelligence and machine
learning
so you can see a quick polio screen
you can respond to choose yes if you are
interested
and know if you are not interested so
you can see a quick pollen screen I can
see most of the folks have already voted
uh for an answer I can see the interest
in the program
and that's great and a few of the folks
who have not voted I would suggest to
just quickly go and vote for the poll on
your screen you're seeing right now
so yeah
so I'll be giving 10 seconds more uh
then we will be closing this poll
meanwhile I'm going to the questions we
have a lot of questions in the Q a box
and we can't wait to take those
questions as well that'll be out
so yeah I'll be closing the poll in 10
seconds
so a few of the folks who have not voted
I can see most of the folks have already
voted and I can see the interest towards
enrolling into the program more so
that's great
you've gotten a lot of curious Learners
here
see I'll be closing the poll in five
seconds
so five four three two one
awesome uh I can see almost 80 percent
of the folks you know they actually are
interested in enrolling this program uh
so that's amazing uh now we'll be
talking about the enrollment steps
uh the enrollment steps are pretty
simple three simple steps all you need
to do is you need to submit an
application uh at ask us at
simplenon.net uh your application will
be going for a review uh once your
application is reviewed you'll be
getting the admission call and uh
admission email from the learning
Consultants from Simply learn now uh I
know someone has asked about the program
fee and the schedule as well so the
program fee is 1 lakh fifty three
thousand four hundred including taxes
INR rupees and in case if you're looking
for financing options they're available
at
522 per month and also uh the cohort is
starting on 16th of September this year
and the induction classes will start
from 28th of August so you have enough
time to study with the class as well in
case you're planning to start
immediately and you can always contact
us at ask us at simplyland.net uh also
just to let you know that we have
limited seats available we only take up
25 to 30
in order to make sure that everyone's
get the special attention uh while
studying in this program by it kanpur
now I would want to know that how soon
do you plan on enrolling in this program
for folks who have selected yes uh most
of the folks like you know from the
previous poll so uh I would suggest that
you can see four options in the screen
it's a very quick Tool uh this is just
to understand when do you plan to enroll
in this program so what exactly is in
your mind are you planning to enroll
immediately so you can select the first
option if you're planning to enroll
within three months you can select the
second one if you're planning to enroll
within six months or more than six
trumps from now you can select the third
or fourth option so for folks who have
selected yes even the folks few folks
have selected no I know you're still
thinking about it if you're just not
sure when exactly maybe six months down
the line so I would suggest for folks
who have Selected Few folks for selected
no they can select the six months or
more than six months from now that's
plenty of enough time uh if you're
interested in this program you know take
that up and not miss out all this bonus
offer you'll be getting you know once
you actually select that you want to
enter Instagram
so yeah I can see the polls moving in uh
so I'll I'll give enough time for folks
who have not voted yet so I'll give like
10 seconds more so you can see a quick
poll on your screen how soon do you plan
to enroll
okay I can see the poles are still
moving so what I will do is I'll give 15
more seconds till we close up this pool
and move on to the Q a part of the
session uh for the Q a participation
while you guys are voting it are
basically how soon do you plan to enroll
and help us out with that information uh
I'm looking at the Q a questions and uh
we'll be taking those questions just
after the school so I'm really excited
about the Q a part after this so yes
so 10 seconds more for few of the folks
who have not voted yet uh I can see most
of the folks have voted so I'll be
closing the poll in 10 seconds
meanwhile folks who are asking questions
in the chat please go ahead and put
those questions in the Q a box uh
because really taking the questions from
the Q a box and we get a lot of messages
on chat I'm so sorry for that we might
miss it so yeah
okay awesome I'll be closing the poll in
five seconds so five four three two one
okay awesome uh we can see that half of
the forks are interested in joining
within immediately or within three
months and a few of the folks are
interested in six months and more than
six months in a row so that's that's
really good thank you so much for voting
now let's move on to the most
interesting part of the session that is
the Q a session
maybe let's start with few questions
from the folks who actually have put
down questions even when before they're
starting the session so I can see oh
palm sugar has asked a question uh good
evening sir I wanted to know how many
projects will we do in this course apart
from Capstone projects also how many
Capstone projects we will do
okay so Capstone would be one and uh
every section will have its own kind of
a mini Capstone you can think of it so
every section will have its own project
so uh I I guess we mentioned six or six
sections total so we'll have six
projects for that and then not only that
uh within the sessions also you'll be
solving some case studies so if you talk
about projects it will be roughly you
can say around
uh including Capstone you can say around
10.
okay awesome I hope that answers your
question thank you so much uh I can see
one question from Ravi I am a mechanical
engineer working in off-road vehicle so
it will be helpful for me as it is more
related to computer and ECE engineering
well if you ask about transitioning into
roles related to AI or data science uh
from a mechanical engineering background
is indeed possible and can be beneficial
especially if you are working on
projects related to say off-road
vehicles that involves data collections
sensors and automation or to give a
little perspective that what kind of
problem you might be interesting in
solving using machine learning AI it
could be predictive maintenance for
off-road vehicles that we talked about
like maximizing the uptime of heavy
off-road vehicles or it could be say
terrain classification for autonomous
vehicles it could be fuel efficiency
optimization that you want to achieve or
it could be Vehicle Health marketing
that you want to do all those places you
can use uh machine learning and AI okay
so a lot of lot of usage of AI uh in the
field of mechanical engineering that you
talk about
awesome thank you so much I hope that
answers your question we've gotten a
very similar question uh that can be
compared to today's web technology in AI
email uh is this going to help with
building applications or replace the
applications uses
well some of them will be replaced it
will become obsolete some of the
application because AI will give you a
newer capability all together and we'll
be building new ones also so but
eventually what is going to happen is is
we're going to build a lot of
applications which will become
kind of uh that's what you want to
achieve like over the counter products
but that's very difficult to do in in
this particular field but eventually
that's what they were looking like
applications which leverages Ai and ML
and it's solving some real-time problem
end users can easily use it without
getting into the nitty-gritties of how
they are working but but in the
background some some algorithm must be
functioning like Google photos for that
matter you have been using it right and
in the background a lot of data mining
is happening which probably you must be
aware also like how it identify who are
there in the pictures okay so all that
awesome thank you so much for your
answer I hope that answers your question
I can see one question uh I am in first
year easy should I start learning AIML
from now if yes how can I start
uh
and sooner the better I would say and as
I mentioned earlier also when you want
to get a good grip of all these these
learning algorithms you should start
from very basic and if you want to
eventually become a data scientist or a
or a machine learning engineer you have
to have a very good knowledge of basic
statistics to advance statistics
programming knowledge and then you
should have a knack of solving some
problem that's what I would say so start
with the statistics and Foundation learn
what is statistics like as simple as as
mean median mode that we talked about or
descriptive statistics that we have in
financial statistics is there
statistical inferences all that you
finish it off and then move to the
machine learning however I want to tell
you machine learning models are totally
different from statistical model but uh
to get a good understanding of the input
which you're providing to the machine
learning model you have to have a good
understanding of statistics
awesome I hope that answers the question
we have a very similar one which you
already answered with this question like
what statistics and Mathematics skills
are required I think I've answered with
this one uh let me let me check out more
questions we've gotten we're still
getting questions here
so okay to what extent should I learn
statistics and Mathematics are Basics
enough or should I have learned in depth
again a similar one if you would like to
answer out anything to that
yeah so I would say in depth in a sense
that if I mention a particular concept
let's say I say uh statistical inference
so you should know how it works why it's
required and what are the techniques
inside it or if I talk about say a NOAA
how does it work so basically I would
say that learn to to that extent that
you are able to correlate that concept
with a particular problem or any kind of
real-time problem to that extent at the
same time I don't want you to get
carried away with that and then move too
much into the statistics part as well
because it's a it's an ocean it has so
many things so start with I would say
start with the basics of it like
understanding simple uh histograms or
problems understanding distribution
probability distributions and then
statistical inference that should be
sufficient to to say that you have
started understanding of a statistical
term and then you move to the machine
learning models
awesome I hope that answers your
question
okay uh we can see uh one question by
Ajay uh I am an ex-ship Captain a master
our exams do not come under university
Mumbai university has given us an
equivalent of graduation I have
completed an MBA with itm Navi Mumbai
and an extra masters with ddg shipping
will I be considered eligible
okay I think so like it should be
eligible right like uh that is something
uh you can also clarify with us at ask
us at sibling.net Ajay okay I can see
Richard has asked a question that I
don't have any knowledge about python
then should I join this course or not
if you don't have understanding of
python uh you need to understand one
thing is that throughout the program
python will be utilized so it's better
to Learn Python but we give a
programming uh refreshers that will take
care of
of it asserted to a certain extent but
honestly telling you think of python as
a as a helping hand you don't have to
become a python developer a lot of
people make this mistake they start
thinking I'll become an expert at Python
and then I will learn learn machine
learning but there are two different
paths all together you don't have to
become a python developer you have to
Learn Python from from the perspective
that you want to use Python for machine
learning so some basics of python if you
just cap just go through and you
understand how the code works that will
be sufficient you don't have to spend a
lot of time on that
well thank you so much I hope that
answers your
Malik uh I have just completed my second
year and have not yet got an admission
in bachelor's program
um okay that's confusing am I eligible
to enroll okay I think I think it means
that he's not completed the degree uh so
uh yeah so as per the eligibility that
you need to have a bachelor's degree so
well I would say that uh three year of
Fourier degree you know whatever dig
you're doing so complete that and then
you can enroll in this program
okay uh let me see more questions uh sir
I don't have uh programming knowledge as
mechanic coming from a mechanical
background or do you start from the
basic so I can grab all the knowledge
and paste on the course in this
particular program
as I already answered this one that yes
we give a programming refresher but
before you come uh you can just do some
pre-reading off on on Python programming
on your own also it's not a difficult
language altogether just to tell you
oh awesome I hope that answers your
question I can see one question from
srirang that can I possibly finish this
in three months if all materials online
and self-driven
sorry come again uh can I possibly
finish this in three months if all the
material is online and self-driven
not really because it's an
instructor-led program where you have to
go through the sessions and there is
eligibility for the certificate based on
the attendance as well
okay awesome uh
I think uh
okay let me see uh as we know that AI is
replacing human effort almost in every
field sooner or later AI model will be
developed which will make AI models
itself a business course to be
beneficial really do not want to mess up
with AI
well if you're talking about distant
future you don't know it's going to
happen tomorrow it's going to happen
after 20 30 years so are you going to
wait for 30 years to decide whether
you're going to do the program or not is
the question so so basically I'm saying
uh
you study this learn how it works and
when the time comes when AI is building
AI then probably we'll take a backseat
right now it's not that case uh it's not
that way so you have to you have to
learn and implement it
Google answers your question we have two
questions questions about the course if
this course is available in U.S and
outside of India as well for that uh
we'll we actually are done with the Q a
part so thank you so much for taking us
uh through this program in detail and
also taking up this q a questions as
well uh I'll be just uh going to the
basically slide where you can actually
scan it and go to the program page as
well for folks who actually want to
check it out for uh outside of India or
the US part so uh meanwhile uh I'm
pretty sure that you need assistance
with enrolling to this program uh so a
little bit of help is required right so
why not get complete assistance from
Simply learn while you want to enroll in
this program so you can see a quick pull
on your screen so let us know if you
need an assistance to enroll in this
program uh this is especially for the
folks who have uh basically voted for
yes they want to enroll this program and
basically they have selected the
duration as well uh why they basically
why and when they want to enroll in this
program so just a quick scold uh to
understand basically do you need
assistance to enroll in this IIT campus
uh professional certificate program in
artificial intelligence and machine
learning
so it's always get to uh it's you know
it's always good to get that help right
like as much as about the program before
signing up so I would recommend to
select yes so please go for the yes
option so you can get all the help you
need before you take up this program
from Simply learn to learn link as I did
so yeah I'll keep up the poll for 15
seconds because I can see most of the
folks have voted uh but for the few
folks who have not voted I would highly
recommend to go and board uh so yeah the
question is like do you need assistance
in enrolling in the IET campus yeah
artificial intelligence and machine
learning's professional certificate
program
uh just to let you know that we are
almost done with the session and I can
see a few of the folks who have asked
about the recording of the webinar in
the Q a so you will be getting a
recording link for the Post webinar and
you can view it again you can go through
it again in case you want to have you
basically want to have much better idea
about the program which Amity has taken
us through and also uh about the webinar
certificate that also will be getting
post program so uh so please like go and
quickly vote for the poll because I'll
be closing the poll in 10 seconds
people are still voting and I can see
that so uh yeah so do you need an
assistant to enrolling in this program
so I would highly recommend to select
yes because you should get all the help
you need right from the learning
Consultants so awesome
I can see most of the folks have already
voted uh and uh they need help so that's
great to know and I'll be ending the
poll in five seconds so five four three
two one
awesome so we can see that half of the
folks actually want assistance so that's
great now uh basically we'll be ending
the webinar so thank you so much for
green being a great audience uh you can
always ask us more questions related to
the program this program or other
programs with simply learn at ask us or
and the rate simplenon.net and folks who
have asked that do we have programs
outside of India or in the US you can
scan this code uh from your mobile and
be taken to the simply learns uh website
where you can actually check out this
particular program as well for your
country and also other programs which
are eligible in your country so thank
you so much again for joining us and
taking us through this program and
answering so many interesting questions
from the Q a box and helping
once before so thank you so much thanks
Alicia it was a pleasure thank you
thank you thank you likewise